la conversion écologique du pape
François dans une encyclique très
attendue sur l'environnement le pape
appelle les gouvernements à l'action
pour sauver la planète pour lui il est
clair que c'est l'homme qui est le
principal responsable du réchauffement
climatique il balaie ainsi l'opinion des
climatosceptiques pour lesquels se
réchauffement a surtout des causes
naturelles et il exhorte les pays riches
les nantis à aider les plus pauvres à
réaliser la transition énergétique bref
c'est un texte très politique qui mérite
vraiment qu'on fasse appel aux lumières
de mon collègue à l'increvier de
l'émission Second Regard Alain c'est
vraiment plus qu'une encyclique c'est
presque un appel à une révolution verte
vous avez raison vous mettez le doigt
dessus parce qu'une un site libre qu'on
imagine que c'est une réflexion du pape
ou encore tout simplement un
enseignement du pape en lisant ce texte
de 182 pages dans laquelle il y a six
chapitres il y en a qu'un seul dédié à
la Bible alors tente lisant ce texte là
on a clairement l'impression que
François est devenu en quelque sorte la
porte-parole des experts des
environnementsalistes des scientifiques
des grandes personnes qui la rencontrer
au fil des mois et des gens en fait une
masse de gens qui ont envie de dire
c'est assez j'irai plus loin que ça
Céline je dirais que j'ai eu le
sentiment que c'était pas tellement une
entité ce que je n'ai de lire mais que
ça ressemblait davantage à un manifeste
et même allons-y ça ressemble à un appel
au combat Orient rien de moins que ça
bon il le fait avec toute son autorité
morale quel impact ça peut vraiment
avoir il y a des gens un impact depuis
quelques jours il y a des gens aux
États-Unis vous savez il y a pas mal de
gens aux États-Unis qui sont des
climatosceptiques et vous avez
maintenant des gens qui sont en
politique qui ont réagi de façon assez
VMH d'ailleurs je pense à rixentrum qui
voudrait bien se présenter auprès aux
élections présidentielles et qui disait
dans le fond monsieur le pape vous savez
l'église votre église a fait souvent des
erreurs avec la science alors peut-être
que ce serait une bonne idée de laisser
ces choses là aux scientifiques Jeff
Bush qui a dit moi je ne prendrai pas
mes politiques économiques de mon évêque
de mon cardinal et pas plus de mon pape
et puis vous en avez un autre sénateur
qui a dit bah peut-être que le pape
devrait se mêler tout simplement de ses
affaires si on me demande si le François
peut avoir un impact dans ce débat la
réponse est oui il y a 1000 fois en
poudre et est-ce que c'est pas un peu
inhabituel pour un pape d'être aussi
politique parce qu'on sait que ça arrive
à quelques mois de la grande conférence
de Paris sur le climat vous avez raison
vous savez Jean-Paul II était un homme
moi je pense que Jean-Paul II était un
homme vraiment très politique c'était
une époque très particulière la guerre
froide l'Union soviétique la Pologne et
il a joué un rôle important dans tout ça
Benoît sale c'est tout le contraire
c'est un homme facile un théologien un
homme de la réflexion et vous avez
maintenant François qui est
véritablement un casse singulier vous
savez il y a deux ans vous et moi on
était à Rome pour le Conclave et on se
demandait à voix haute d'ailleurs on se
disait est-ce que le fait que cette âme
là Vienne d'Argentine d'un pays du Sud
un pays du diamant mais c'est un pays en
développement du Sud est-ce que ça va
changer quelque chose ben vous avez la
réponse maintenant c'est très clair les
192 pages de cette encyclique respirent
le sud on a l'impression que les
préoccupations de ceux qui ont souvent
été bafoués où ignorées sont présentes
dans sa dans sa réflexion c'est tout au
long de ce de cette encyclique qu'on a
cette chose là alors je vous dirais que
oui puis à partir de maintenant vous
allez le voir ce qu'ils vont ce qui va
prendre le relais ce sont les paroisses
des milliers de paroisses qui vont
prendre le relais de François dans ce
discours là vous allez avoir après ça
François qui ira à Washington à la
Maison Blanche à l'ONU au Congrès et
puis ensuite en décembre la grande la
grande conférence de Paris alors tout ça
ça s'inscrit dans un mouvement auquel
François tenait à participer on va
continuer de suivre le pape François
avec vous parce que ça c'est intéressant
ce qui se passe merci beaucoup ça me
fait plaisir